these were emotionally charged moments
for relatives of the 96 Hillsborough
victims another step towards reliving
the horror of the disaster another step
towards what they hope will be justice I
feel like this is our first rail inquest
the last one I don't think it touched on
a lot of the main problems Hillsborough
and i believe it was their inquest the
police the last one in 91 and this one
is for the 96 it's got to be hard for
all the families for what we might may
say we might want a horrible and it's
got to be the truth and that's something
we've campaign for all the time we need
to get justice for all of drugs so they
can rest the original verdicts of
accidental death were quashed in 2012 in
the light of fresh medical evidence now
25 years after the tragedy the largest
inquest hearing in UK legal history is
underway there needs to be a court
process that looks into all of the
issues in detail and that's what this
King quest is it is all about from
wednesday families will begin to deliver
what have been described as pen
portraits of their loved ones statements
described by barristers as exquisitely
sensitive and important such as the
complexity of these proceedings that
selecting the jury has in itself being a
mammoth task 1000 people initially
received summonses as potential jurors
and that figure has now been narrowed
down to 11 11 people who will be asked
to devote the next 12 months of their
lives to these inquests investigators
considering criminal charges against
organizations and individuals are
following the inquests meticulously so
many people are investing such a great
deal of faith in the outcome rarely has
there been a procedure surrounded by so
much hope and expectation Mike McCarthy
Sky News Warrington
you